welcome everyone I'm Martin Higham and
it's this is the second of our Frankie
lectures which have been made possible
by the generosity of Richard the Barbara
cranky and and Gary introduce tools
here's last times I won't go over all at
the end but this we have the sense of
the formatted speakers the speaker comes
to customer Tippin is sitting in on the
banking seminar and then giving a
lecture and then having dinner with the
students so it's a it's a really
exciting format for everyone involved
and it's particularly great pleasure for
me to welcome professor Robert Pittman
to Yale Tippin is the Evelyn Steffensen
Distinguished Service professor of
social thought and philosophy at the
University of Chicago and given that to
you by now is the author of some 15
books just for you the titles will take
most of the time and have for this
introduction so what I want to do is
that it just give a very synoptic
account of different importance for
contemporary work in the humanities
while mentioning only a few is many
influential books and which range from
velocity to literature and art all the
way to Hollywood westerns and quinoa so
at the heart of Pippins work and stance
a book from 1989 entitled vehicles
idealism and I think it's extremely rare
for a work of secondary literature and
philosophy to have a kind of
transformative effect and enduring
legacy that happens book has had both in
anglo-american philosophy and in Germany
Piven did not focus that in powerful URI
the idea that Hegel is some sort of pre
critical and totalizing meta position
instead showing why Hegel may be the
most sophisticated of all post company
and philosophers up until the present
and this is perspective uh Kipnis
continued to develop Fuki Galen
engagements which philosophers such as
Nietzsche door now and Heidegger as well
as in this book Gong Hegel's practical
philosophy which not only reconstructs
Hegel side lexical notion of freedom but
also shows why this notion free
offers profound challenges many
contemporary philosophical paradigms so
not just the historical relevance in
Hegel but the contemporary philosophical
relevant legal in the way it allows us
to challenge for example naturalistic
counts of action or moral individualism
now all this would be impressive enough
in itself but Pippen has also pursued
his they elected a lot of action in
sophisticated agents with authors such
as country James the massive boost as
well as for reading some modern art
someone can say that Tibbett never
forgets the interdisciplinary and
historical vocational ah Satish that's
remaining true to Hegel dictum that
philosophy should be its own time
compounded in form however what I
think's even more remarkable is that
tipping does not choose between an
emphasis from a practical social and
historical constitutional agency on the
one hand and he goes logical
metaphysical ambitions on the other on
the contrary as it has made clear in his
recent work on the science of logic if
we understand Hegel's claim that logic
is metaphysics in the right way we will
understand why it is crucial for
grasping white historicity and sociology
are essential and irreducible it would
be a mistake to call Hegel's concerns in
the logic abstract rather they concern
the most general conditions of sense
making and thereby they have concrete
implications for our understanding of
who of everything we do in everything we
are now I can testify first ham to the
sort of excitement that is generated
when one begins from Stan this claim for
the past four years some of us here at
Yale have been reading the science of
all being systematically and Hitman's
new essay all the science of logic had
accompanies us as we have done so indeed
in these four years I've often had
students coming to my office declaring
that all kipman just published a new
essay on the logic with the same kind of
excitement that you would declare that
your favorite band just released one
song yeah and happily I can declare that
the album is now about
have a great title Hegel's realm of
shadows come to think of it that would
be a great name of a rock that people
swam with shadow style stadiums Pippen
may not be something else State this
stadium even though I think he should
but he's one of the most vital and
important thinkers alive so I'm very
excited too thank you very much
this is the second time I've had the
pleasure of Martin's informed in
complimentary introductions I wish I
could just record them and take them
with me it's very kind of you to invite
me I do feel I should perhaps apologize
a little bit for this lecture when I got
the invitation I heard that there was
this Frankie seminar and that they were
discussing heidegger's being in time and
I know that Martin's interpretation of
Heidegger is very much I would call a
Hague alien interpretation of Heidegger
I thought I would read something on
heidegger's criticism of Hegel which is
what this paper is my compulsion to
apologize is that it will sound although
I agree with Martin it isn't but it will
certainly sound excessively abstract
just by virtue of who Hegel and
Heidegger are they they don't write in a
way that is easily accessible and I will
do everything I can to make the
abstractions of both of them accessible
but I I feel humbled by the task and I
hope I've I've made clear what's at
stake between them because I think it
bears quite a lot on the kinds of things
I heard discussed this afternoon in the
in the seminar the project from which
this paper is drawn is a philosophical
engagement with the tradition of anti
Hegelian ISM in modern European thought
a critique which I want to show amounts
to an attack on what I consider Hegel's
version of idealism and ultimately on
systemic philosophy as traditionally
understood which Hegel is thought by
many people to have brought to some sort
of
conclusion idealism in this tradition
should not be understood as a claim
about the mind dependence of the world
or about mind and pose structure in
experience or as a so-called objective
idealism a claim about the non-material
nature of the real in favor of its ideal
nature but first and foremost as an
objection to empiricism the claim that
all knowledge is or must be based on
empirical experience itself
paradoxically an opera claim by contrast
idealism in consciousnes and Hegel is a
claim about the capacity of pure
empirically unaided human reason to
determine of all that is knowable that
it is knowable and how it is knowable
since this amounts to a claim about the
normative authority of knowledge claims
by what right we claim what we claim to
know
and since reason it is reason alone that
demonstrates can demonstrate such
normative Authority this must mean that
human reason is to be understood in a
way that begins the paradox that is
Hegel to be self authorizing a tribunal
unto itself in the Hegelian version this
determination of the knowable is a
determination of all that there is in
its no ability and so is in metaphysics
the determination of the knowable is not
for Hegel the determination of a
limitation as if a limitation just to
the knowable for us or in Hegel's famous
and controversial phrase this
determination this self-determination by
reason of its own requirements is
absolute and so is as he constantly says
a determination of the absolute of all
that is in its no ability that is of all
that is in other words idealism in this
sense invokes the deepest principle of
all Western rationalism to be is to be
rationally intelligible there can be
nothing a logos or unintelligible
obviously this all rests everything of
significance on the determination of the
necessary requirements of
intelligibility what Hegel called a
logic and why we should think that such
a determination sets out what Kant in
another kind
it's called not merely the logically
possible but they're really possible the
position obviously does not hold that
there is nothing unknown but that that
there can be nothing in principle
unknowable that the logic of the form of
the knowable can be fully determined
this then would clearly amount to a
claim about the conceptual structure or
logic of what there is as is well known
many of the most influential figures in
this period roughly 1807 until the
present in European philosophy
considered Hegel their chief opponent an
animus also shared by the likes of
Schelling Kierkegaard Marx Heidegger
Adorno Derrida de Lewis Bataille
Foucault leotard and Livy knows so
there's some sort of strange Freudian
moment in which Hegel is the big daddy
who has to be killed before philosophy
can begin again and that that dimension
I'm not going to talk about but it's not
really supplanting your predecessor of
position well known here at Yale but
killing him off once and for all for
good and they often explicitly did so
attack Hegel by identifying him as the
epitome or culmination of all Western
philosophy itself the dispute in one way
or another concerns an attack on that
idealist claim for the autonomy and
self-sufficiency and self authorizing
character of rational reflection and
especially against Hegel's claim for the
absolute status of the results all in
favor of various versions of the
finitude or limitation of human
reflection now these interpretations
often draw large implications from what
I believe to be a distorted
interpretation of Hegel however the
proposal tonight is not that all of
modern continental philosophy rests on a
mistaken interpretation of Hegel many
other issues were certainly in play but
the contest station between idealism and
anti idealism between the self
sufficiency of reason and it's putative
radical finitude is of major
philosophical importance in itself there
is a way of genuinely understanding
Hegel such that this long critical
reaction certainly has some real grip on
a real problem
in other words while it's true that the
received Hegel interpretation is for me
largely inaccurate porting this out
hardl hardly settles the issue the
central challenge to idealism which I'll
sketch below is still a very powerful
one the basic claim in this long
tradition about the insufficiency of
idealism or pure thinking or even
systematic philosophy is important
enough to warrant that kind of
interrogation my suggestion will be that
Hegel's potential contribution to this
discussion has been both misunderstood
and undervalued and the central claim is
that when the ambitions of what Hegel
called pure thinking are properly
identified the criticisms embodied in
the finance argument that I want to
identify while interesting and important
don't hold but first I have to proceed
to a ridiculously brief summation of the
Hegelian ambition itself so here goes
the central idealist claim began with
Kant's critique of Pure Reason and his
assumption that reason was capable of
determining what it was entitled to
claim and capable also of restricting
itself when it could not provide such
authority the first critique is itself
an exercise of Pure Reason exercised on
itself
this almost immediately generated the
concern that such an enterprise would
not only end in a destructive self
devouring skepticism but in an all
destructive nihilism Jacobi's original
coinage leaving nothing of moral
substance or objective status standing
but a deeper and more long-standing
issue arose in the thought of Hegel
especially in his attempt at his major
theoretical work the science of logic a
book that has not until very recently to
say the least enjoyed much of a
reception in either Anglophone or
European philosophy the issue of that
book looks like this
Hegel's claim has three components the
first is to claim that a priori
knowledge of the world the ordinary
spatio-temporal world is possible
a priori knowledge of the world
knowledge about that world but achieved
independently of empirical experience
obviously Hegel does not mean knowledge
of how cholesterol is produced or what
caused the extinction of dinosaurs but
knowledge of the right understanding of
the substance property relation the
for matter relation essence appearance
relation universality and particularity
relation and so forth the second
component is where all the controversies
begin it is the claim that this a priori
knowledge while in some sense to be
specified ultimately about the world
consists in thinking or reasons
knowledge of itself
thinking's determination of thinking or
as Hegel designates it a science of pure
thinking this is what determine
distinguishes classical rationalism from
post Conti and idealism as Hegel
understands the horror holds that reason
has access to its proper objects outside
itself non sensible entities monads res
kogi tongs platonic IDs the latter that
the object of pure thinking is only
itself but there is clearly a question
to be answered how could the first two
components a priori knowledge of being
and pure thinking pure thinking's object
being itself possibly be jointly true
one long dominant interpretation of
Hegel on this point the third component
and the putative resolution of this
tension between the first two wholes
that these two claims can both be
assertable only if what there really is
the really real world what is accessible
only the pure reason alone is itself
something like thought thinking moments
perhaps something like the absolutes are
God's thinking itself an inherent
evolving noetic structure unfolding in
time from the human perspective
Spinoza like absolute in itself pure
thought thinking itself is the
manifestation of the no ASIS no a ciose
God thinking himself or it is the divine
like apprehension of a noetic reality
that underlies experienced appearances
that would certainly resolve the tension
I can't do so here but I've argued for
many years that this interpretation does
not at all fit the text so an alternate
interpretation is necessary and I'll
discuss that in a moment but apart from
the interpretation issue the various
critiques I am interested in all hold
that any such project is doomed from the
start that there is not and
cannot be such self-sufficient pure
thinking in other way it's another way
of saying that there isn't such a thing
as philosophy traditionally understood
philosophy is a non-empirical enterprise
it's pure thinking it's an attempt to
determine an answer to questions like
what is art what is religion what is the
good life non empirically purely so an
attack on pure thinking is ultimately an
attack on the possibility of philosophy
I noted that such a broad counterclaim
is often summarized as a doctrine of
radical finitude this is an apt title
says Hegel insists that to use an
Aristotelian formulation thinking
thinking thinking is not the thinking of
any object and when he wants to
summarize such an unusual reflective
self relation he notes what he calls the
infinity of thinking's relation to
itself
he means pure thinking's object is
itself but not as an object or event
rather its object is the thinking also
interrogating thinking a circle not a
dyadic relation hence the provocative
notion of infinity without beginning or
end subject or object the criticism
holds that thinking must always be
understood as grounded on or dependent
on or an epiphenomenon of some sort of
non thinking ground or absolute or
materiality or contingency or the
unconscious instinct or drive of the
thinker Schelling's early formulation is
apt the distinction between thinking and
what is other than thinking between
subject and object cannot itself either
be a subjective or an objective
distinction if it were either there
would actually be no distinction so what
there really is can be characterized
neither is absolute subject nor absolute
object but here the difficulties with
Shelley begin somehow the neither
subject nor object Hegel's
prioritization of the concept in his
terms the identification of the absolute
as the concept intelligibility itself is
said to be by shelling a prioritization
of absolute subjectivity and so require
only one relation to what is
other than thought nature pure
domination hair soft it would be hard to
overstate the influence of such an
argument the details vary a great deal
of course but the form of skepticism
remains from shelling to heidegger to
Adorno especially but the
counter-argument I want to defend is
that Hegel's treatment the topic of pure
thinking has nothing to do with the
thinker the subject consciousness the
mind the topic rather rather raises as a
problem the possibility of the
intelligibility of even whatever is
being touted as preconscious source or
hidden origin the intelligibility of
what has assumed that any such
determinate identification as a
knowledge claim even of the so called
neither subject nor object that must
still in the most general sense makes
sense within some general regime of
sense making or nothing has been claimed
an empty space and logical space would
have just been suggested any such
criticism insofar as it is a thinking a
judging a claim to know is always
already a manifestation of independence
on pure thinking and its conditions and
such moments of pure thinking are to
delimit but not limit the normative
domain of intelligibility what can
rightly be distinguished from what or
rightly posited as ground for example
and not any process or series of events
that goes on and suppose that
independence of the empirical world pure
thinking as Hegel understands it is
neither dependent on nor independent of
the empirical or materiality or the
brain or the indifference point or
whatever new absolute comes into fashion
his position would be better understood
at least at first by rough analogy with
Fraga or Wittgenstein of the Tractatus
or the early Husserl on logic as
metaphysics that anti Hegelian question
already manifests for the hague alien a
misunderstanding of the question of pure
thinking itself this is not to deny that
any reference to thinking presumes a
thinker indeed a living purpose of
finite embodied rational thinker Hegel
addresses that issue in his philosophy
of subjective spirit
is phenomenology and elsewhere it is
rather to argue for the autonomy of the
question of any thinking at all
whatever the existing existential status
of the thinker that is it is to insist
on the priority and autonomy of what
Hegel called logic and that means for
him a complete self determination of its
own moments
Hegel's enterprise in the logic takes as
its topic the categories or thought
determinations necessary for thought to
have determinate objective content an
enterprise that at the same time
specifies the determinations inherent in
the possible determinacy of any being
itself it is true that it was seen that
Hegel is subject to his own criticism
that pure thinking must already assume a
determination of what pure thinking
amounts to but Hegel's innovation here
derives partly from FIFA and one of the
hardest aspects of his thought so I'm
sorry about this is that pure thinking
comes to self consciousness about itself
just by thinking in the sense that one
understands what it is to believe by
believing what it is to act by acting
not by means of any self observation I
mean something here simpler than it
sounds when you are doing something you
know what you're doing by doing it you
don't know what you're doing by doing it
and observing yourself doing it when you
want to know what you believe you
attempt to figure out what you believe
you don't intend to inspect your beliefs
you're trying to figure out what do I
believe you end up believing what you
believe by believing it and knowing what
you believe by coming to believe it
same with acting same with thinking you
know what it is to be thinking by
thinking not by inspecting yourself
thinking that's essentially the method
of the logic but I don't I don't pretend
it's immediately pellucid
put a different way it's how Hegel wants
to get out of this paradox that a
science of pure thinking would already
be pure thinking that's captured in this
paradox of infinity
not having a beginning and in his
response start thinking think being
which is the beginning of the logic and
you'll find thinking being can't be a
thought it must be determinately
distinguishable from something it isn't
to be a thought
I say etc is if everybody's familiar
with the first moment of the logic but
you get the point I hope put a different
way if Hegel we're making a claim about
the minds thinking nature how we must
think about the world knowledge would be
limited by its instrument something
Hegel had been vigorously denying since
the introduction to the phenomenology in
1807 in knowing itself what pure thought
knows is the possible intelligibility
the know ability of anything that is but
the intelligibility of anything is just
what it is to be that thing to be
determinately this such tota t the
answer to the what is it questions TST
definitive of metaphysics since
Aristotle to be is to be intelligible
determinately what it is so in knowing
itself thought knows of all things what
it is to be anything again for Aristotle
the task of metaphysics is not to say of
any particular thing what it is it is to
determine what must be true of anything
at all such that what it is
in the particular can be determined by
the special Sciences of course the
physics and the de anima are also
philosophical sciences for Aristotle
although they're not first philosophy
when Hegel will also have a philosophy
of nature and a philosophy of spirit
aside from the science of logic but the
analogy with such things as frege's and
Husserl's critique of psychologism only
goes so far
not only because Hegel's account of how
pure thinking determines the necessary
moments of the intelligibility of
anything at all already a distinctive an
unprecedented position but also because
it involves a further argument about the
bearing of such results on the
intelligibility of nature and human
practices this feature of Hegel's
position which it is
among these critics an understandable
frustration the relation between the
logic and the philosophy of nature and
spirit touches on another major
dimension of the anti idealist critique
one most associated with shelling
Kierkegaard and Heidegger it is that
thought paradigmatically Hegel's pure
thinking or even philosophy itself as
traditionally understood cannot finally
contribute to any understanding of
cannot in effect even reach the most
vital concrete issues faced in human
life existential issues I mean this is a
traditional critique of all philosophy
that it's abstractions can't help us
with the problems we face as the
concrete human beings we are this is
another implication in the critics of
what they consider the finitude of
thought and it is argued more and more
radical ways of addressing illuminating
understanding in some way such existence
issues are needed Hegel certainly cannot
contribute to this goes the criticism if
Hegel is understood as he seems to
require interrogating the role of reason
some normative order in the changing
socio-political religious and artistic
practices of an age but again this all
depends on the proper understanding of
what Hegel means by such an appeal to
Reason in such practices and my claim is
or will be that once the proper form of
the structure of rationality or account
giving and justification in the logic is
understood its bearing on the issues
Hegel himself brilliantly brought it to
bear on ethical life art religion can
finally be properly appreciated some
kortek I have a scholarly conscience so
I have to bore you with some quotations
I want to prove to you that Hegel is
saying what I say he's saying because
what I'm now saying Hegel is saying most
people who work on Hegel do not believe
Hegel is saying so I have to now put
some quotations on the board
hurling Hegel quotations at you at 5:30
in the evening is not polite but I
as I say I do have a I do have a
scholarly conscience
this is Hegel I don't see how anybody
can doubt what I'm saying but they do
almost all of them but this is what
Hegel says thus logic coincides with
metaphysics the science of things
grasped in thoughts which used to be
taken to express the essentiality zuv
things he means the things outside used
to be taken to be about things rather
than pure thought it's about things
grasped in thoughts which is the only
way thought things can be intelligible
as thought we should note this change in
emphasis by Hegel the new metaphysics
logic concerns things as grasped go fast
in thought whereas the old metaphysics
were the thing metaphysics used to think
of its subject matter as on to outside
itself the essence of things or the
objective logic which are the first two
books of the logic this takes the place
rather of the former metaphysics which
was supposed to be the scientific
edifice of the world constructed by
thoughts the object of pure thinking is
only pure thinking again a logic alone
takes the place of the former
metaphysics and finally a longer
quotation the older metaphysics had in
this respect a higher concept of
thinking that now passes as the accepted
opinion which is that thinking is just a
subjective activity a psychological
process for it presupposed as its
principle that only what is known of
things and in things by thought is
really true VAR hast vara in them that
is what is known of them not in their
immediacy but as first elevated to the
form of thinking as things of thought
this metaphysics thus held that thinking
and the determination of thinking are
not something alien to subject matters
but rather their essence or that the
things and the thinking of them agree in
and for themselves is not a
correspondence view in and for
themselves that thinking in its imminent
determinations and the true nature of
things are one and the same content not
their thinking corresponds to things but
termination by thinking of the
requirements for any intelligibility by
thinking is if so facto a determination
of the intelligibility of anything that
could be and thus an answer to the
question potentially what is it so does
this all put us in any better position
to understand the skepticism from the
finitude of thought objectors consider
some of the most immediate pressing
objections which I'll turn now to I'll
have time to consider two objections
although at the level of abstraction and
distance from various text I'll have to
be subjective rather than definitive but
we have to start with an objection again
as a matter of scholarly conscience
before we can even get started from the
content camp which rejects this whole
enterprise the second is from shelling
this point of view and finally we'll
conclude with heidegger's response to
all of this is it not obvious says our
comms scholar that any proposed
identification of thought and being like
that asserted in the last quotation
simply ignores rather than answers
the famous question that marked the
beginning of critical philosophy for
comp and his famous famous to some of us
February 21st 1772 letter to Marcus
Harris this is the letter in which he
claimed to have discovered quote the key
to the whole secret of metaphysics
unquote a question he said he had
neglected in his 1770 dissertation the
question is what is the ground of the
relation of that in us which we call
representation to an object and quote
the axioms of Pure Reason concerning
leads to these objects how do they agree
with these objects since the agreement
has not been reached with the aid of
experience isn't Hegel when all is said
and done a regression to uncritical
thinking dogmatism rather than some sort
of progress beyond Conte and his
supposedly objectionable subjective mind
imposed unity new mental ignorant
idealism it's absolutely correct to note
that Hegel does not answer
Kant's question as much as rejected as
confused and resting on its own dogmatic
presuppositions part of that rejection
is supported by what he thinks he
accomplished in the ena phenomenology of
1807 but it's also internal to the
stance of the logic first such an
objectionable presupposition is obvious
when Conte had noted that pure concepts
are that in us which purport to be
concepts of the real though as Canton
went on to say quote they must have
their origin in the nature of the soul
they are neither caused by the object
nor do they bring the object itself into
being all creating for him the
objectivity problem a gap between
thought and being pure thought pure
thinking empirically unaided thought and
being that must be closed
somehow Hegel does not want to close it
he wants to reject the assumption now
Karl and Hegel certainly share what has
been called the discursivity thesis this
means simply that thinking what thinking
is for both is exclusively a spontaneous
or productive power in no sense a
perceptual or passive receptive capacity
it would be very hard to exaggerate the
magnitude of this common assumption in
Conte and Hegel more than anything else
it sounds the death knell of traditional
rationalism the light of Reason
available to the world and it plays a
crucial role at the decisive beginning
of the logic where Hegel demonstrates
that mere being can be no actual thought
at all
it's indeterminacy renders it a mirror
nothing without some other and that
means some predicate of determination
other than the mere thought being for
its determination that's the
discursivity thesis thought is an active
productive power ultimately judgmental
power not a passive intuitive power
content reasoned that since the mind and
hear his crucial failure for Hegel since
the mind is open or receptive to the
world that we all know the world around
us now only sensibly and since thinking
cannot create the objects it thinks
then thinking cannot provide itself with
any content can only be provided from
content from without through sense
experience this would normally lead
straight to empiricism and probably an
empirical skepticism - but Kant believed
he had discovered that there must be
pure forms of sensible intuition and
this provided him away he thought in the
deduction of the pure concepts of the
understanding to connect the pure forms
of thinking with pure forms of passive
intuition and thus get in view as it
were a priori all possible objects of
experience and argue for the validity of
the categories for such objects this of
course had the effect of restricting
those results for only possible objects
of our sensible experience with our
forms of intuition thus initiating the
Hegelian complaints about his subjective
idealism and Hegel had two main
objections first conte was hasty and
arguing from the discursivity thesis to
the claim that pure thinking can provide
itself with no content contem self had
demonstrated that this was not so since
in what he called his metaphysical
deduction he had himself shown that pure
thinking could give itself content that
is it's all necessary logical moments
the categorical features without which
judging could not be judging could not
be any sort of truth bear so we can
return to the Hegelian claim pure
thinking's proper object is itself Hegel
has no hesitation in saying several
times that thought in the logic provides
itself its own content or produces its
content its own conceptual moments
eventually substance property form
matter essence appearance concept
particular and so forth that there was a
method for demonstrating that thinking
itself must be thinking with these
moments for Hegel was for many after him
conned himself didn't even attempt to
show how this derivation was
accomplished
he claimed misleadingly that he simply
followed Aristotle's list that had been
lying around for centuries although that
of course was not true he essentially
made it up moreover conte had realized
that such forms of thought alone already
provided what he called a clue a light
fought in a guiding thread
the categories as forms of objects so a
link between the forms of thought and
the forms of being was already in play
for con ii cart had already realized
that the pure forms of thought were not
just features of a human thinker
we're not psychologically subjective but
necessary for any discursive thinker
whether human or not when that just
means any non divine thinker but since
these forms of judgment are the forms of
any possible truth bear and since truth
is either truth or not it makes no sense
to say that these forms to limit
something like what is true for
discursive thinkers there's no such
thing as truth but just for X the
subjective izing element in Conte are
the species-specific pure forms of
intuition not the forms of thought and
once we reject the doctrine that there
are such things as pure forms of
intuition as Hegel does we can return to
a positions like Aristotle's where we
can effect in effect study being by
studying the forms of predication in
arya kuzmin's fine phrase quote
predication is nothing but the logical
or discursive face of being unquote so
Hegel thinks content that galectins own
achievements in the metaphysical
deduction and in what Hegel humorously
called Kant's fear of the object
necessarily unnecessarily subjective
eyes his results its contours uncritical
and dogmatic not Hegel's Schelling's
differences with what would become
Hegel's position on logic as metaphysics
are already apparent by implication in
his early work I assume many of you know
that shelling was slightly older than a
younger than Hegel but much more famous
in the early part of the 19th century
and brought Hegel to llena as a kind of
mentor and was furious when the
phenomenology came out in 1807 and Hegel
had put in a lot of clearly recognizable
insults to his sponsoring you know
they're killing the father issue on this
case killing my son
his 1797 ideas concerning a philosophy
of nature is 1800 system of
transcendental idealism he was already
breaking for Hegel the lecture she gave
in 1802 1803 and on philosophy of art
and then finally has later explicit
objections in lectures he gave in Munich
in 1827 to the late 1830s called
lectures on modern philosophy issues are
all very large and unwieldy
but they concern a basic conflict
between a claim about what is always
already presupposed and so forever
unavailable for discursive articulation
by pure thinking versus a claim about
the absolute as we've introduced it as
always a result from which a ground can
be retrospectively reconstructed and
developed but the specific claims are
well known however unwieldy these large
issues are there is first the issue of
ground some sort of ultimate source that
would account for the difference between
and yet also the identity between
subjects self-conscious thinkers and
free agents and objects material but
living productive nature the difference
in their positions implies that Hegel's
position said in the language of the
appear of the period which I hope is got
a vague ring of intelligibility to it
that the absolute is the concept does
not resolve but simply avoids this issue
of ground the ground of the concept John
thinks it's question begging to consider
it a concept second a related issue with
an objection to Hegel's philosophy of
nature that Hegel prioritizes the
concept to nature treating nature only
in terms of its conceptual
intelligibility whereas the concept must
be understood somehow to emerge from are
always already depend on nature and in
the later lectures the problem is
existence for showing shellings charges
that Hegel's program is never able to
exit the realm of the merely
conceptually possible the Galleon
philosophy can deal endlessly with what
some possibility must be to be the
possibility it is but this has nothing
to do with what there is with the
facticity that as shelling puts that
something exists Hegel's results are
locked up in the merely conceptually
possible in what shelling calls negative
philosophy
each of these objections is worthy of an
independent study but the outlines of
Hegel's response involves the suggestion
that some ineffable ungroomed what what
selling out and a half joke called the
ground as non ground because unavailable
for determinate thought because always
presupposed the objection is that does
not even amount to a philosophical
position the language of the claim is
well known from the preface to the
phenomenology where Hegel clearly
referring to shelling who certainly
noticed is that all of this is an
attempt to pass off quote its absolute
as the night in which as one says all
cows are black unquote which he calls
quote an utterly vacuous naivete in
cognition unquote one indeterminacy
claimed as source is indistinguishable
from any other possible candidate if it
is differentiable a determinate position
then such a source has some sort of
conceptual determinacy and falls inside
the moments of the concept that's why
the concept is absolutely that which in
principle falls outside the thinkable
designates nothing at all such an
unconditioned in is nonsense to be sure
shellack has a lot to say about the role
of art and somehow manifesting this
discursive lee unmanned a some
unmanifest above ground but I don't
believe it affects the basic determinacy
point the ineffable remains simply
ineffable but there is a deeper and more
important point behind Schelling's
concerned as he would put it if there
are both subjects and objects thinkers
and things they think about then
ultimately they still have incompatible
properties so how is it possible that
pure thinking self-determination could
somehow help us understand how that
could be unless we are metaphysical
duelists and Hegel certainly isn't isn't
it obvious that we need some account of
substance that could explain how
self-conscious thinking and self
determining agency could emerge out of a
material world otherwise devoid of these
capacities if so this would seem to lead
us into Schelling's language of a
materials name
self negating of its own self-conscious
materiality something that might be
easier to understand if we also follow
shelling into a notion of the absolute
that manifests itself as both a living
material nature with this capacity for
self negation and the results of that
self negation which can be identified as
neither I'm sorry about the obscurity
that's always shelling talks Hegel
treats this way of looking at the
problem as a complex of category
mistakes the question of the
evolutionary conditions for the
emergence of consciousness and language
is an empirical question just as is the
question of what capacities the brain
must have for there to be consciousness
and language use again the proper
question is philosophical or in Hegel's
terms logical in his encyclopedia system
the transition from nature to spirit is
not a question of substance at some
point and it doesn't matter for
philosophy at one point or how natural
organisms reach a level of complexity
and organization such that they begin to
become occupied with themselves and each
other and eventually to engage each
other and to understand themselves in
ways no longer appropriately explicable
within the boundaries of explanations
proper to nature considered apart from
such capacities Hegel's language about
this is everywhere practical not
substantive it is not that Hegel is
denying that self-consciousness and
intentional agency are facts in the
world he is simply claiming that no fact
about the organic properties of such
beings accounts for what it is to be
self-conscious or agents and that that
is the prior question those are
categories of achievement for Hegel
indeed collective achievement and the
question of what is achieved is for him
an autonomous philosophical question of
course what he calls spirit Geist
remains embodied and so subject to mixed
explanations in which it's natural
properties bear on its activities as
spirit things like age geography and
diet this is what Hegel calls in the
encyclopedia anthropology and he has a
lot of interesting things to say about
it but fundamentally spirit is said to
be its own quote self liberation from
nature and spirit is a another
paradoxical phrase a product of itself
and its actuality is that it has quote
made itself into what it is
consider this famous passage from the
lectures on art art which is one of the
means of this self liberation by means
of its representations while remaining
within the sensuous sphere liberates man
at the same time from the power of
sensuousness of course we may often hear
favorite phraseology about man's duty to
remain an immediate unity with nature
Hegel's not a romantic but such unity in
its abstraction is purely and simply
rudeness and ferocity and by dissolving
this unity form an art lifts him with
gentle hands out of and above
imprisonment in nature it's a little
extreme even I don't believe that that's
it's got to be a better way of talking
about our relation to nature and
liberation from prison it doesn't matter
that there are also natural scientific
explanations of what happens in the body
and brain when all this occurs what say
when we make or enjoy art the question
that's emerged the only emergence that
is relevant is whether the norm art has
in one instance or another been rightly
and fully realized or whether the
justifications agents offer each other
and themselves can in fact be defended
whether the structure of ethical life is
consistent with the potential of such
self liberating beings there's no need
to appeal to a vitalist self directing
nature to account for any of this as
we've been seeing the dynamic for Hegel
is historical not biological even though
it clearly has numerous specific natural
organic conditions correspondingly the
question of the possibility of freedom
is not for Hegel a question about how a
spontaneous causal agency exists in a
material world his theory is a
self-realization theory and that asked
for the right achievement in our
understanding of ourselves and in our
relations to others again for him a
historical
and social question not one that
descends from any account of substance
likewise Hegel does not treat the
concept as the ground of the existence
of nature or in any ontological sense as
prior to nature the minimal way to
characterize the transition from logic
to the philosophy of nature in the
encyclopedia is that the transition
entails that the conceptual structure of
any interrogation of nature or spirit
cannot be coherently understood as
wholly empirically determined again
we're talking about all those issues we
mentioned before and finitude infinity
limit unlimited substance property
accident necessity contingency
possibility appearance essence and so
forth each s all of that must Hegel
things be manifested in a philosophical
account of nature and the philosophy of
nature his his attempt to show that it
is as nature was understood at the time
each aspect of the real philosophy
should be shown to depend in some way on
a non derived conceptual structure
manifested in its pure form in the logic
this characterization of dependence is
not incorrect but it still admittedly
doesn't distinguish how Hegel thinks of
that relationship in a way that will
exclude the common sense notion of an
empty subjective form being filled by
objective empirical experience or
imposed on extra logical material he
doesn't mean that this can't be right
because on Hegel's approach any
conceptual structure already determines
a determinately intelligible empirical
content but a gut it does not and should
not determine or derive or certainly
deduce as people sometimes think Hegel
wanted to do the existent content itself
or passages around 250 in the philosophy
of nature where he said it's the last
thing you want to do it like persists as
an interpretation of Hegel as he says in
the penultimate paragraph of the
encyclopedia logic the method is not an
external form but the soul and concept
of the content from which it is
distinguished only insofar as the
moments of the concept even in
themselves in their respective
determinist
I have come to appear as a totality of
the concept of any intelligibility at
all but the move to the Encyclopedia
philosophies of nature and spirit in
that move the identity of form must mean
that we should also attend a logical
form but now understood as in some way
inflected by attention to the form of
what is wholly other than pure thought
in space and time and the form of human
action in the world including collective
human action what does the inevitability
of the distinction between essence and
appearance look like in the
manifestations of the natural world and
in the manifestations of human practices
in historical time how do we make use of
that distinction if it's crucial to
rendering any such practice intelligible
we tries to show us in that account the
conceptual structures laid out in both
parts aspire to a conceptual or opry
truth start getting over a cold even if
the results of the empirical sciences
and historical actuality are everywhere
incorporated this is largely what Hegel
means when he says frequently that
spirit seeks to find itself in nature
and in its own practices it seeks to
understand them to understand their
intelligible form but has already noted
this is not because Hegel thinks of
either part as a result of a simple
application of the moments of it being
an essence logic to an external
indifferent matter
in fact Hegel himself makes the very
point that shelling in the later
lectures considers a damning criticism
of Hegel the idea is still logical it's
shut up in pure thought the science only
of the divine concept it's systematic
exposition is of course itself a
realization but one confined within the
same sphere because the pure idea of
cognition is to this extent shut up
within subjectivity it is a strange word
the impulse disa bladed and pure truth
becomes as final result also the
beginning of another sphere and science
but this transition to a consideration
of nature is not a deduction of nature's
existence nor could it be it's once
again described in practical terms as a
felt practical insufficiency than any
full comprehension of the results of the
logic last section
by far the deepest in my view and most
thoughtful engagement with Hegel thought
in postage alien philosophy is
Heidegger's in fact a good case can be
made that his is the first genuine
confrontation with Hegel in all of the
postage alien traditions for our
purposes the discussion that's
essentially important is what was
published as the second part of a book
now called identity and difference
originally a seminar and later also a
lecture the Anto theological
construction of metaphysics this is
because Heidegger goes immediately and
directly to the heart of Hegel's
enterprise and states it accurately as
just what it is
Heidegger tells us the subject matter
the czaka of thinking for Hegel is
thinking and he immediately adds exactly
oh thank you so much it kind of you
exactly the right qualification in order
not to misinterpret this definition of
the matter thinking as such in
psychological or epistemological terms
we must add by way of explanation
thinking as such in the developed
fullness in which what has been thought
has been and now is thought I'm not sure
that's the most lucid explanation but he
is at least trying to exclude the
psychological and empirical at trying to
give us an account from the nature of
thinking as thinking in Hegel as an
independent topic not as a matter of
psychology or epistemology thinking in
the fullness of what has been thought
its heidegger's a formulation of the
Hegelian claim that logic properly
understood is metaphysics the thinking
of pure thinking is at the same time the
thinking of the world in its think
ability what has been it is now being
thought he reminds us that we can only
understand this beginning from Kant's
view point although not like current
transcendentally
speculatively that is Hegel thinks
thinking as being Heidegger tells us and
not as a subjective epistemological
condition or as add event in an
immaterial world or
Heidegger realizes that pure thinking's
taking itself as object does not result
in a mere theory of thinking or the
rules of thinking or a philosophy of
pure cognition as Heidegger says
directly for Hegel quote being is the
absolute self thinking of thinking these
are obscure and hard thoughts but I
think it's obvious I think already from
the quotation Heidegger has got Hegel
exactly right and if he's going to have
a criticism of Hegel it will be powerful
because he's understood Hegel
the last thing Heidegger means by this
is that being is mental activity whether
human or divine that would merely be an
account of one of the beings a
subject-matter of one of the special
sciences and would presuppose a logic of
intelligibility because of his own
approach Heidegger is in a unique
position to realize that the
subject-matter of the logic is not in
any sense whatsoever a being and not the
absolute self positing not the noetic
substructure of the world not abstract
objects not the mind of the Christian
God not a substance but in his language
the meaning of being theirs in designs
as he puts it in his distinctive
language the being of beings reveals
itself as the ground that gives itself
ground and accounts for itself
thinking's determination of its own
moments the ground the ratio by their
essential origin are the logos in the
sense of the gathering of beings and
letting them be this is high degrees I
sorry about that
they are the hand Ponte they all one
thus science that is metaphysics isn't
truth not logic we now understand the
name logic in the essential sense which
includes also the title used by Hegel
and only thus explains it as the day for
that kind of thinking which everywhere
provides an account for the ground of
beings as such within the whole
in terms of being as ground that is
Lucas the fundamental character is Anto
Theo logic the divine at stake and in
what Heidegger means by Theo logic is he
constantly explains not a being not
anyone and he goes so far as to say
count to whom we can pray or play music
or dance to he notes almost with a hint
of contempt on tell theology is over for
Hegel the theology that considered God a
being and Hegel was for him the first to
realize that the divine aspect of
thinking has nothing to do with a beings
thinking but to the absoluteness of
thinking because in Hegel as a
culmination of all metaphysical thinking
thinking is divine because it's self
grounding and serves as ground for any
being being intelligibly what it is
because of all this thinking is also
theology because it concerns the causa
Sooey so in summation from Heidegger
metaphysics responds to being as logic
and is accordingly in its basic
characteristics everywhere logic but a
logic that thinks the being of the
beings and thus logic which is
determined by what differs in the
difference
Anto theologic the difference between
being and the account of any of the
beings the particular sciences as we'll
see Heidegger means that metaphysics is
determined by this difference between
being and the beings without metaphysics
and Hegel included being able to think
this difference properly it is and
remains unthought and metaphysical
thinking compare what higher is what
Heidegger is saying - what Hegel says
and the accuracy of Heidegger's
characterization will be immediately
clear the logical needs to be thought
this is Hegel in a system of thought
determinations in which the antithesis
between subjective and objective in its
usual meaning disappears this meaning of
thinking and of its determinations is
more precisely expressed by the ancients
when they say that news
the world by our own saying that there
is reason in the world by which we mean
that reason is the soul of the world
inhabits it and is imminent in it as its
innermost nature its universal or you
once you could see that in Hegel's
intuitively if you're coming to this for
the first time I tell them what to say
if you're coming it for the first time
but if there is a kind of intuitive
rejection of all of this as if Hegel is
saying we can sort of pull the basic
structure of reality out of thinking
spontaneously and there isn't much
reason to believe we could we could do
anything even putative lis that and then
very little reason to believe initially
that the results actually because the
self determination of pure thinking
count as what it is to be any
determinant being that give us the
moments necessary for anything to be a
determinate big
that's not Heidegger subjection he
thinks all that's just dandy that this
is the the key insight into what all
metaphysics has been trying to do he
just think there's something unthought
in it and that the unthought is what
we're now going to hear more about how
digger has a problem with metaphysical
thinking he notes approvingly that
Hegel's approaches developmental we come
to the determinations of thinking by
trying to think first of any object at
all being thinking being anything at all
and then determining what we would have
to think to think even anything at all
but it's developmental not deductive and
that this developmental thought thinking
thinking is intertwined also with the
history of thought with the history of
philosophy and his engagement with this
thinking Hegel tries to think rightly
what really has been thought in the
developing positions and that Hegel's
attempt is a sublation of preserving and
raising up of all that has been rightly
but partly thought into a whole
Heidegger accepts this intertwining with
the history of thought but he says his
own approach is to think what has
remained forever unthought in the
metaphysical tradition remains hidden in
the history of thinking as logos
accordingly he says his engagement is
not an elevation or sublation
not progressive but a step back or
scripture Luke while Hegel thinks the
ultimate identity of thinking and being
Heidegger's basic thought he says is
difference difference
thinking's determination of actual
absolute intelligibility actually he
says recedes before the true subject
matter of thought being itself something
remains unasked the difference between
being and the beings again recall I
always find it helpful to prevention
Aristotle Hegel follows aerosol the task
of first philosophy is not to determine
of anything what it is but to determine
of anything at all what it must be such
that the question what is it could have
some purchase that's the Hegelian
version of what Heidegger calls the
ontological difference first philosophy
and the special on tech sciences of what
is it of the beings Heidegger is
objecting that this leaves unasked why
the think ability of any being is
limited to what it is to be a being that
leaves the question of being qua being
simply assumed already determined as
thinkable determinacy itself but that
means its unthought just assumed why
should the meaning of any being of all
beings be the determinacy of being as
just what it is you might think well so
what if it son thought not a very
interesting thought to think something
other than that hi do you guys want to
make an enormous amount of hay out of
that that this question is unthought
presuppose dogmatic the meaning of being
shouldn't be understood immediately as
the conditions necessary for the
determinacy of any being there's a
deeper question about being and meaning
that isn't asked so in conclusion if
Heidegger has rightly characterized the
nature of Hegel's project and I think he
has what isn't in the logic as
metaphysics project in Hegel that does
remain in this sense unasked or
unthought as just noted the answer is
supposed to be this absolute differ
between the meaning of being and the
meaning of any beings which is what
drives the logic how to come up with the
conditions of determinacy and Hegel with
Heidegger is just saying that leaves the
question of the meaning of being unasked
this is of course Heidegger's master
thought throughout his career but what
does the thought and the criticism mean
in Hegel's terms the first thing one
could say is that Hegel is Heidegger is
right about the logic Hegel does insist
that the question of being necessarily
always amounts to a question about what
it is to be this or that being that's
correct
Hegel does believe that that's the
result of the first moment of the being
logic and it is that moment where the
deepest confrontation with Heidegger
must take place but as Jess noted Hegel
formulation doesn't seem to reach the
question Heidegger is interested in
since it is for Heidegger I'm thinking
we already oriented from the question of
the intelligibility of anyone being Zion
de in Heidegger's terms as Heidegger
realizes the closest formulation in
Hegel for the question the being of
beings the meaning of being itself is
simply pure thinking determinate
intelligibility that is the meaning of
being but that topic which Heidegger
wants to treat as beings own
manifestation the meaning of being it's
unconcealed or happening and so what
pure thinking or judging must presuppose
that think that topic in Hegel is not a
topic or moment from of pure thinking
there is no interrogation of whether the
meaning of being is intelligibility
determinate intelligibility in the logic
although we've reached the point where a
very great deal would have to be said
about Heidegger's unusual language it's
also here that we do seem to reach some
sort of absence in Hegel's enterprise
even if whether that means that
something crucial is missing or not is a
separate question if the being of beings
the absolute is think ability have we
asked in the logic what it is what it
means to be thinkable think ability is
not one of the determinant moments of
the logic and when judgments own
characteristics become self conscious in
the last part the count
logic it's just the forms of judging
this or that in their determinant
possible inferential relations that is
attended to I noted before that Hegel
thinks we cannot provide an independent
theory of the thinkable as such we can
merely manifest thinking by pure
thinking we know what pure thinking is
by thinking like action like belief any
other formulation would presuppose and
so elude itself but this means that the
science of pure thinking does and cannot
count pure thinking itself as one of its
moments and from Heidegger's points of
view this is not adequate a massive
criticism of Western rationalism follows
from this point in Heidegger what we
learn in the process of trying to think
anything at all determinately is that
the possible determinacy of any being
can be made out thinking thinking
thinking is the enacting of thinking and
the reflective self consciousness at the
end of the logic the concept of the
concept of intelligibility itself is a
form of self consciousness about the
intelligibility again of any being not
something like the thought of being as
intelligibility itself that is always
unasked unthought presupposed even if
everywhere for Hegel unavoidable
manifested enacted the concept logic is
supposed to allow the inclusion of the
logic itself inside the concept but that
just covers what we've been through in
the book what thinking of any being
amounts to it does not and cannot
include what Heidegger seems to be after
what does it mean for being to be
thinking self-determination of thinking
that question both must be and cannot be
inside the concept
put another way logic itself or the
question what is logic is not a possible
moment in the logic and we know from
Heidegger's 1928 lecture course now
published as the metaphysical
foundations of logic Heidegger thinks
that question is deeply intertwined with
the meaning of being question so
Heidegger is right I think that the
question remains unthought unasked it
can't be
but this also raises the question of
whether Heidegger is right to draw the
rather apocalyptic consequences he does
from this supposing forgetting or not
asking the question
also raises what might seem like an
unusual question from Heidegger's point
of view is all of this actually a
problem it's not as if Heidegger thinks
this elusive topic should have been a
moment within the logic that would have
turned it into a moment of determinacy
itself he is in many other works asking
for other modes of interrogation that's
why his work becomes so strange for a
first from a fundamental ontology form
of phenomenology to such strange notions
as Galison hide or release mmus or on
Dinkin or kind of pious thinking or a
Dinkin that he says as a duncan of
thinking - the intimation of the
fourfold kind of farmer metaphysics of
earth and wind and sky but from Hegel's
point of view there is no reason to
believe that these attempts would not
generate their own form again of
difference and so elusiveness and for
Hegel this would be because the only
kind of interrogation of being there
could be is the interrogation of any
determinate being and the mode of those
determinations thought determinations
denk Bashar Momin it might be hiding
garyun enough for Hegel to invoke
another formulation of the same problem
that think ability as the meaning of
being can only be shown not said thanks
for your patience that was a lot
[Applause]
yeah you speak a little bit about how
Hegel's logic is related to his theory
of the struggle for recognition in which
you know you mentioned earlier someone
you're out there the being somehow
emergent of nature and interacting with
each other
but I want you to want to hear a little
bit more from what you think about how
the structure of biological
consciousness and our ability to self
reflect and all that is conditioned by a
particular interaction between human
being whether or not Hegel in some sense
presuppose what he set out to prove by
embedding the potentiality for such
thinking in these creatures that do
interact and then from there in the
interactions emerges some kind of
optimistic conclusion and whether or not
that's something justifiable or not yeah
I mean the first thing one has to say is
something about Hegel systematic
enterprise so the basic statement of the
Galleon philosophy is not the 1807
phenomenology which was a kind of
introduction to it where the most famous
passage about the struggle for
recognition of opposed self
consciousnesses occur but the
encyclopedia of the philosophical
sciences 18 17 18 21 1833 different
versions of it and the structure of that
is logic philosophy of nature philosophy
of spirit in the philosophy of spirit
there's a section called phenomenology
and it's there that the struggle for
recognition is a moment in the
articulation of the intelligibility of
human practices how human beings engage
each other in the struggle to become
self conscious beings so that prompts a
second point which is there's no reason
to think that every problem in Hegel is
a historically inflected materially or
socially relevant problematic the
science of logic is not it's pure
philosophy it's it's a science of pure
thinking the thinking of any
intelligibility there is though in the
science of intelligibility in general
way of understanding why a person's own
free self-realization should be
dependent on the free self-realization
of another which is not a standard way
of thinking about freedom
the basic doctrine of freedom and Hegel
in the philosophy of spirit that is as
he tries to understand how the basic
structure of any intelligibility can be
seen to be manifest in the account of
human practices he gives him the
philosophy of spirit in the enterprise
that that's part of he then confronts
the fact of a singular desiring agent
who confronts I'm not really as sick as
I sound another singular desiring agent
and ultimately the position he wants to
reach is a conception of freedom which
he calls being a self in the other
selves I'm in the under design that's an
extremely unusual relationship it means
that the limit what appears to be the
limitation originally of your own
restricted activity by virtue of another
person's occupying finite space isn't
really a limitation that it's the
condition of its realization but so the
longer answer to your question would be
how a different way of thinking about
the relationship between self and other
which is ultimately grounded in the
essence logic in the science of logic is
manifested in what was at the time and
it's still today an inspiring but deeply
unusual thought that I can't be free
unless you are normally it would just
seem I could just be free fine and it
may be unjust or unfair that you can't
be free but that relationship that being
a self is being a self in the other I
mean here's examples of freedom for
example the primary one is love and the
other one is friendship those are the
true manifestations of human freedom in
which the presence of others are not
limitations on the exercise of my agency
but conditions for its objective
realization but all of that depends on a
very unusual I mean the simplest way to
respond all that depends on a very
unusual thought that's the normal
relationship between a finite being and
it's restrictive other is a very limited
way of thinking about it and if
we understand the course of the logic
will come to understand better something
about the relationship that will help us
understand how it could be that we'd
reach this really unusual point the
point itself is given flesh and bone by
Hegel and blood inside of a kind of
phenomenon illogical account doesn't
refer to the logic and the two points
can be separated you can make what Hegel
is trying to say lucid just in terms of
the concept of phenomenology itself if
you understand what that is doing in the
philosophy of spirit but ultimately as I
said there's an unusual thought behind
it and the easiest way to answer your
question is just to say we need to think
about that thought because it's a very
unusual thought is not limited by the
other but the other question being as
such each and every finance termination
particular being as such whereas the way
you put read Hegel it's true that this
question remains our ask but only
because this is the appropriate way to
ask the questions
[Music]
so if there is a certain I mean is this
racing
the sensation and I think I'm asking for
something in criticism of Heidegger yeah
that he's hoisted by his own infinity
petard or something like that yeah I
like that but I yeah I mean depends on
how one characterizes the rather
indirect way Hegel is raising the
question of the meaning of being as such
I mean it does manifest itself as think
ability and it manifests itself by
attending to all the possible ways in
which it could be constrained limited
and incorporating them into it into the
by so systematically destroying the idea
of the in principle unthinkable the in
principle unintelligible as an empty
position so it does emerge in that sense
but I think that the problem with
Heidegger is that and this is a very
difficult thing to summarize in a way
that why's you know he doesn't want the
meaning of being questioned which looks
like he's saying we don't have an answer
for it I want now an answer it's exactly
what he doesn't mean he means that the
the idea that there's an absence in this
question that we need to fill is
metaphysics I know you're saying well
what's the point of raising the question
if there isn't a you know kind of
determinate answer to it but Hegel
Heidegger thinks it has a bearing on us
it what looks like it's absence it can
be rethought we don't really understand
what it is to be and in a way there's a
kind of finality to that in in Heidegger
that he thinks we have covered over so I
mean I think his position is more
radical than the ironic rejoinder it
just is then it opens the question of
well
if it's more radical what's he talking
about well if he if he means there's a
constantly and he you know by the end of
the 30s and the 40s he's already talking
about what what being is in its
manifestation is its concealing its
revealing and concealing structure is
all that there is to the meaning of
being and that's in a way from a
Hegelian point of view not a very
satisfactory yeah exactly and you reach
a point where there's almost a kind of
begging the question standoff
because Heidegger is going to claim that
the assumptions by which this is
unsatisfying in Hegel are just in a way
begging all the questions that he wants
to raise whereas Hegel is trying to say
well no you're you're you're begging the
question by assuming there's always
something outside of the regime of
intelligibility I mean in a way that's
kind of an empty port you can always
just say well how do you know there's
not something outside the realm of the
regime of intelligibility in Western
metaphysics and I mean how come what may
be it can emerge historically or
something like that
all Hegel can say is give me one show me
like what and then begin to ask under
what conditions is that identifiable as
the thing you're pointing to and
Heidegger then throws up his hands so
you're begging the question again you're
invoking the regime I don't want the the
police called and that question asked me
I want you to ask her answer it without
the police and Hegel says that's begging
the question that is not the police for
God's sakes you know that kind of thing
so it's very very delicate I find myself
more and more sort of bothered that I
haven't quite understood the force of
Heidegger's problem I get more and more
of the sense that there's something
there that there's something about the
Hegelian self enclosure that is
problematic in a way that's quite
significant for the history of Western
thought in general for this sort of the
arrogance of the sort of
self-satisfaction of reason I'm started
a little more bothered by that than I
was twenty or thirty
ago so I'm trying to understand this but
I can't quite get over the high
daguerreian whatever it is Bridge to the
promised land
I still think it's just Hegel seems
right what is the source of thinking
rather how does one introduce at some
point some region where they're now able
to follow this to Guinean no imperative
just do thinking how does it get to know
I mean I think Hagel has no objection to
that question teresting question how do
how do children come to think nothing of
another question what is it to think how
did human beings come to first make art
what is art two different questions
one presupposes the other now nowadays
we're you know post damn toe and
everything we're willing to say the very
difficult issue for Hegel because Hegel
thinks on the one hand that what counts
as art is a historical development that
there there are different conceptions of
art in different historical periods and
that we can give an account of the
genesis of art not too many the genesis
of the human desire for art although
that might be an interesting question in
itself so forth but it presupposes that
we know what we're talking about when
we're doing neuro esthetics and we think
we've identified art I mean most of the
people who do know our aesthetics don't
care about that question they just hook
somebody up and show them some god-awful
print of something they say I look at
the pleasure centers lighting up and
there the blood flow into those sections
of the brain something like that but we
don't want to be satisfied with that as
philosophers who I don't know why is
that crap they're looking at called art
it doesn't seem to me to be art but
since Hagel has a developmental account
of the changing structure of what counts
as art over historical time
he still nevertheless wants to say that
there could be manifest in some
societies practices that are called art
as if they're in the same tradition and
they're not that's a difficult position
the latter sounds more essentialist the
former sounds more historicist and the
great virtue and great problem of Hegel
is he exactly wants both it is true that
art is a historical practice that
changes its shape and function and
nature over time but there's a limit at
some point things can be paraded around
as art that aren't art and we should be
worried about that we shouldn't let that
concept go it's too important I mean for
Hegel it's a sensible effective mode of
understanding the absolute it's a it's a
mode of self understanding that we want
to understand in its specificity but the
question of either the historical
generation of the category or the
psychological generation of the capacity
to appreciate it in children or
something like that those are for him
empirical questions that are fine but
the point to be made and this drives
people somewhat crazy because it's a
kind of arrogant assumption that first
listen to the philosophers and let them
figure out what art is before you go
worrying about wiring people up when
they experience it but the next step is
there's no agreement in philosophy about
what art is so it doesn't do any good to
go consult the philosophers you consult
fifteen different positions but Hegel
thinks you know he's got an answer to
the question and all you can do is try
to try to give it but he doesn't think
of it as subject to empirical stories
about its genesis as part of the answer
to what it is that's that's the
philosophical question
says I have a question on something that
he said they make at the beginning of
this knowledge of the spirit plane can't
confer bathe it but he said something
like this could either be taken as the
road to truth or whatever but it could
also be regarded as a pathway to doubt
and let's get this in front of despair
yeah be genuinely is off there generally
is a choice of interpretation on the
readers part so do you think it's my
first question if you think it's
plausible that this is an implicit
concession on people's part to the kind
of person support assistant that she'll
in later brought up but it's only that
get a philosophy agree that need to be
quite impossible yeah the second
question is do you think I mean how does
hydrators announce except the
fundamental meaning of being let me try
the first one first I mean it isn't up
to the reader according to Hegel it
might what he's trying to say is a lot
of people are frustrated with philosophy
because every time there's a settled
philosophical school of thought or
position like empiricism in Britain in
long rationalism then comes in peeresses
and then comes Conte then comes Hegel
and people throw up their hands and say
well philosophy is just constantly self
devouring enterprise why should I bother
with it there's never any kind of
answers and higgles first response is
it's not bad that philosophy is a
self-critical evolving enterprise that
might look like the pathway of despair
but philosophy is all about this moment
of self negation
that's how philosophy grows into a more
adequate historical position this
assumes that the course of positions in
philosophy has a kind of intelligibility
to it very few people think that any
more if anything they think that there
are just several classic philosophical
options in the firmament and when you're
in graduate school you should pick one
and read the latest stuff on it and work
on it
Hegel wants to ask well how did they get
to be the positions that are canonized
as the firmament what does it mean that
they're in opposition to each other in
the way they
or is there any way of thinking about
that that can look like the pathway of
despair but it isn't that's a promise on
his part and if you keep faith with
Hegel you have to at least give him a
few years to try to convince you that it
makes some sense that the basic
positions and philosophy has developed
have developed as they have and that
they can put in to be put into a code
coherent whole
the thing that people who are attracted
to Heidegger find so pressing about his
questions is to put it very simply
everything I've been saying about Hegel
you could put by saying the assumption
that the determinations of pure thinking
are the determinations of being is not
some sort of fancy speculative identity
that cannot be denied it's the
imposition of a regime of sense-making
on an other to thought that is
considered the mere material for thought
Heidegger's account of the history of
philosophy is radically declension us
rather than progressive it's just the
opposite of Hegel's once we start from
the assumption that to be is to be
intelligible we've made what there is as
being subject to our regime of
intelligibility Hegel thinks the our
there is question begging and wrong but
you can see the force of what Heidegger
is trying to say and the ultimate end of
this story is what Heidi recalls
technology the technological and framing
where we understand ourselves and the
world as material for some kind of
rationalist imposition of some kind of
intelligible structure our own bodies
become medicalized and materialized as
subjects for scientific enterprise for
example or something like that we begin
to understand ourselves differently
because this regime of sense-making has
been imposed on something that doesn't
have its own voice that has just
incorporated inside the machine this is
even though Adorno keeps saying how much
he hates Heidegger for those of you who
know Adorno you know this is something
Adorno swallowed hook line and sinker
that Hegel represents the epitome of
philosophy as a kind of great devouring
mouth
consuming everything in its own
self-satisfaction so that I think the
people who are really genuinely
influenced by hire or find him in
college or graduate school when they're
reading him a warning sign of some
respects is that this makes some sense
to them not so much skepticism but to a
kind of appropriation of being for the
sake of the intelligible that isn't a
speculative identity but an
appropriation a devouring a manipulation
subjective hubris self assertion of the
point of view of Western rationalism
that needs to be guarded against
comparative Heidegger's big influence to
convince people there was a danger here
how do you recall the denials the
classical view which Hegel is the last
one to share me I put it this way this
kind of sound kind of crazy but that
being is good what does that mean being
is good it it allows its own
intelligibility it is not hostile to us
it it it is appropriate to our demands
that it be made intelligible you can
easily imagine that that would not be
the case and your another way of
answering your question is how does
Hegel know it's not the case maybe
there's just a whole bunch that we think
we've rendered intelligible that lies
out and we've we've left a lot of stuff
out and I've tried to say before and
that question is an idle question for a
ver until you bring up something and
tell him he can't deal with it and as
soon as that happens he sort of has you
but Heidegger doesn't think being is
good he thinks it hides that's why he
loves Heraclitus nature hides right is
there somebody else what to ask yeah
suggestion regarding how to understand
the front leg between Heidegger in the
terms of your you know the truth and I
would suggest maybe we part of this
reform plan is the question so because I
would say yeah because and I think this
might be you the wheel of like the
question rather than the question
because I think from the beginning but
from being in time and with what what
understanding as Lawson hides and so on
is he combines a certain sense of
spontaneity with the certain sense of
I think this is the beginning of yeah I
think you're certainly right that is a
point of great possible contestability
between them the trouble is one needs to
I don't think I think you probably would
agree that by introducing the notion of
I mean there's all these Los Angeles and
Los Angeles and I'd kind of phrases even
in even no I mean even in being in time
there's there's quite a lot of stuff of
letting something be or letting
something approp approach you or not
letting it approach you because all that
already you're quite right already in
being in time now the problem is that I
think we would agree is not a reversion
to the rationalists or platonic notion
of Nueces because it's not fixated
traditional rationalism believes that
there is such a thing as a priori
philosophy because Pure Reason has its
special objects that only Pure Reason
can attend to non sensible objects
monads thinking substances platonic
ideas forms God that's traditional
rationalism and it's receptive in the
sense in which there's a light of Reason
a light of nature an oasis and intuition
by virtue of which the undeniable 'ti of
a claim can be maintained by virtue of
having seen it of there being an
intuitive light of reason that is not
what Heidegger is trying to revert to so
then the question is for what because
there is also in Hegel's notion and
consolation of productivity
that thinking is discursively sort of
predicated or judgmental there has to be
a kind of passive moment of seeing what
you've done there has to be already a
kind of complimentary it's just that the
seeing the passivity is focused on
itself it's still there because you know
if you predicated and determined there
all kinds of implications you have to
see you have to see what else are
committed to you you have to see what
you've just done you have to see the
alternatives that you've excluded yeah
all that has to be in some sense part of
your awareness so there is a passive
moment it's just the idea that the
fundamental activity that's primary is
discursive thinking judgment and
judgment judgmental or predicated now
Heidegger in his own notions of
assertion and so forth is trying to work
around that in his lectures on logic
he's very aware but I'm not convinced
that he's given us a way of really
understanding what this passive on
Dinkin Callison hide moment a dunken a
receptive a letting be moment amounts to
because what Hegel is going to always be
interested in is its object and
Heidegger will resist that that's not
the right way of thinking about it
there's a it has more I mean I I'm it's
got to start sounding like Scientology
or something but the even passivity is
probably not the right way to put it but
I see what you're you're asking he wants
being to be a kind of sight a clearing
victim of their big yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it doesn't it doesn't have a
particular object that's just the point
it's the site at which the meaning of
being both manifests itself and
withdraws both but this I find this all
very hard to understand but as I say I'm
not completely convinced there isn't
something left out of what is kind of
their complete self determination by
thinking of its own possibility in Hegel
or by any form of traditional
rationalism at work in Anglophone
philosophy or critical theory or or just
about anything else
there's not something radically left out
but the the alternative although it
doesn't have to do with any kind of
passive perception of objects in
Heidegger
it's just for that reason hard for me to
get my my hand or I don't know what a
clearing is yeah the question of being
mean as you said return to the beginning
allowing or restarting I think that
seems to me to be like the productive
productive clean we're not reading we're
not reaching our solution we're out
reaching completion so that's exactly
what honey good means yeah I think
you're exactly right that's what he
means
okay we go back to Parmenides and
Heraclitus everything everything
everything bad starts with Plato which
is you know it's kind of I miss is one
of the things got him her his best
student in a way and his most influenced
student could never swallow that
beautiful plato is the beginning of
nihilism but that's not that's that's
Heidegger's claim
I'll get you you said that God is no
longer a being which in the letter
humanism yes there's a short one think
about the fact God being valued and that
being an island itself so I especially
with his later stuff from especially it
seems like they are beings unless I'm
misunderstanding on the other hand to be
also says that the default of God is a
default to be absent so I just wanted
you to elaborate well I mean what became
the idea of religion after Anto theology
in theology which was quite influential
since Heidegger is now probably the most
influential figure in contemporary
theology became so called negative
theology I mean my my colleagues
jean-luc Mariana is the epitome it's
good that God died now he could be God
that kind of thing it's it's really by
negative determination that the
manifestation of God as not a being but
but the meaning of all being can be can
be manifest so I mean the letter on
humanism I mean you have to take into
account first of all that especially
what he says about Marx Heidegger is
writing and occupied France he wants to
get back to work and so I think a lot of
that the letter on humanism which was so
influential in France is a political
document meant to protect himself he
knows whether they're coming for him and
so all of a sudden Marx is a great
thinker God is God don't let it be a
value it's just a lot of BS in that
letter the later stuff on Anto theology
is all consistent with the rejection of
God as a being but that doesn't mean
there's not a religious element in
Heidegger I don't I don't quite mean to
say that but there is a hesitation to
adopt any of the traditional Christian
theological apologetics that we know
from scholasticism
is that - just another he doesn't talk
much about religion I never think it
takes seriously policy ism as a moment
in Greek thought as much as he he
focuses mostly on philosophy I I think
he thought they were I mean there there
is the question of Aristotle so he does
have a lot of things to say about
Aristotle and what's interesting about
Aristotle which he sort of comes close
to understanding is that when you ask
yourself you you know I mean one version
of your question before about children
is well yeah we we know about thinking
pure thinking by trying to think why do
we try to think where does that come
from the animation for philosophy so
there's a dynamic erotic component to
the beginning of the enterprise of Hegel
we want something we we want to think
where does that that's not part of
thinking that's the condition of
thinking it's an erotic desire we need
completion we need to think why do we
need to think where's that in Hegel
where is the origin of the logic there's
a phenomenological introduction to the
logic that explains why in thinking we
would come to the standpoint of absolute
thinking pure thinking thinking itself
that doesn't answer the question what is
the place of thinking in a human life
where is it a game that we play or is
there something connected in the opera
of everyday life that makes pure
thinking ultimately inevitable these are
very vague questions but there isn't
really a kind of approach to them in
Hegel and well there isn't I mean that's
not quite true there's a long question
but there is something more of the grip
of a question like that in Heidegger the
meaning of being having an existential
priority
whereas in Hegel if you ask well what is
the point of the unthinkable 'ti of the
pure thought of anything at all what is
the point of it what's disturbing about
it why started there isn't there's
something left out maybe that's one way
of saying what's left
what Heidegger is worried God there's
something left out the meaning of
thinking I mean in all the ways
Heidegger means the question of Zinn or
meaning its significance for us it's
unavoidable 'ti it's pressing this it's
dramatic necessity is absent in the
beginning of the logic with what must
science begin is a first section of the
logic that's all about logic about being
where you want him to answer the
question there's somewhat different way
yeah I mean this is there a--does great
objection to Hegel he doesn't have a
very what a modern philosopher would
regard as a very sophisticated theory of
language it's a vehicle for Thought
thinking isn't
I mean it's embodied in human language
but not in a way that has philosophical
weight to it for Hegel we you know we've
we've come to think differently but I
just think I have to admit that I don't
think of there being in Hegel much of
philosophical weight attached to the
fact that thinking is linguistic it's
there there's a kind of belief in pure
concepts as moments of pure thinking
self-determination that can be embodied
in any language it's much different in
hiding who does think language is the
house of being and I was just you know
completely different but that already in
a way it's post hare there in the German
tradition that all of this became much
more pressing and Hegel was not really
influenced as as much as he could have
been by order just I don't ever find it
a very interesting topic in tables he's
not that good on
[Applause]
[Music]